and ma'am if you could please state your
name for the record Kylie oage thank you
and good morning to you ma'am and good
morning to detective main as well with
that you may proceed with your statement
this morning
ma'am good morning um my name is Kylie
oage I have attended Oxford Community
Schools for my entire
life
I often look back at pictures of me and
my parents in
2009 walking into my first day of
kindergarten I was so innocent with my
Barbie
backpack my My Little Pony lunch
box at the time I didn't know what a
school shooting was no child should at
that age let alone Experience
One
I was so innocent on that first day of
kindergarten and that innocence was
taken from me two years
ago I was a senior at Oxford High School
on November 30th
2021 that day began like any other for
me I drove to Oxford Middle School in
the
morning where me and my friend T Meir
and I were partners for Bully bu ERS
which was a bullying prevention
program Tate and I spoke to sixth
graders about bullying in the school
environment and how to prevent
it afterwards I drove back to the high
school where I took a math
test I ate lunch at the same table that
I sat at every single
day I made Tik tocks with my friends in
the
hallways before my fifth hour class me
and my dear friend Riley fron and I were
standing in the hallway socializing with
our
peers and all of a sudden I thought a
balloon
popped I turned and I fell right to the
ground I remember hearing screams I saw
running but I couldn't run I was already
down I remember hearing Mr Wolf make an
announcement I had never heard the Halls
become silent so fast in my
life silence was
deafening I was laying on my side like
this and I realize what had just
happened I was just shot and I thought I
was going to
die as I laid on the
floor I attempted to get up but my legs
weren't
moving I repeatedly hit my legs with my
hands like
this an attempt to regain any kind of
feeling any kind of feeling but not a
single
thing I then somehow tried to do a
pushup to somehow drag my body to a safe
place where I could get some
help but with the weight of my car heart
jacket and my backpack full of laptops
and
textbooks I was unable to do
so it was so
painful I let myself drop back down onto
the
floor where I felt warmth on my
face warmth from blood soaking into the
carpet I remember hearing a squish sound
against my right
ear and it was the sound of carpet mixed
with blood going into my
ear I started yelling for help but when
I say yelling I mean a shout that was
loud enough for someone around me to
hear yet quiet enough for the shooter
not to hear
me no one ever
came but I did hear
something I reached my hand over my head
and I realized it was
Hana I could hear her groaning inside
me realizing that I wasn't alone I kept
trying to reassure
her someone will come help us don't
worry just keep breathing just please
stay with me I said that to her a
thousand
times at one point a SWAT team member
came running past
us he was the first person I had
seen I pleaded to him please help
us he did a double take and said someone
will come back for
you Hanah and I were left in utter
loneliness and I thought I was
dying I kept repeating my mom's phone
number to make sure my brain was
functioning I was creating math problems
in my head and solving them to make sure
I wasn't
dying I continued to yell for help
15 M 15 minutes of laying there
absolutely
helpless 15 minutes of lying in a pool
of my own
blood 15 minutes of hearing Hana St
Juliana's last
sounds while stroking her hair and
trying to encourage
her when help finally came they attended
to Hana attempting to wrap a tourniquet
around
her someone eventually came came for me
too I didn't know who it was but I knew
it was a man and I later learned that
that man was Mr Ken
Weaver Mr Weaver stayed with me
supporting my head and locating my
wounds he kept pressure on my entrance
wound to stop the
bleeding Mr Weaver fought to keep me
awake and alive until the paramedics
could attend to
me during the ambulance ride I kept
asking paramedic will I still be able to
ride my
horses will I ever be able to play
basketball again I kept asking these
questions to the paramedic in the
ambulance these were my favorite
activities while growing
up I was transported to St Joseph's
Hospital in Pontiac where I stayed into
January during my Hospital stay I spent
one week in the Intensive Care Unit and
over a month in the Rehabilitation Unit
the bullet entered me through my right
clavicle and exited out the left side of
my
back the bullet shattered my right
clavicle broke two of my ribs and grazed
my spine causing a spinal cord
injury that night I had an emergency
surgery to remove a hematoma from my
spinal
cord also to take out the shards of bone
from around my spine along with pieces
of clothing that had entered along with
the bullet
one week later I had a clavical repair
surgery where they stabilized my right
clavicle with a titanium
plate during my almost five week stay in
the rehab unit I had to train myself to
sit up on
assisted I had to relearn how to perform
basic life tasks like eating brushing my
teeth showering and getting
dressed I had to learn to walk again as
well as climb
stairs prior to this event I was being
recruited to ride horses competitively
on a college Equestrian
Team unfortunately I cannot follow
through with this
opportunity I've been riding horses my
entire
life I've had several horses throughout
my lifetime they have provided me with
years of
happiness being able to swing a leg over
my horse is my therapy
it's pure joy and I have not been able
to do this in two
years before November 30th I also had a
great job working at a golf and country
club I love my job and I love the people
there but unfortunately I was unable to
return to work and have not had a job
since due to my disabled
condition and I have not been able to
earn any money for
myself 7 months after being discharged I
became a freshman at Michigan State
University where I'm continuing my
education carrying on with my life
because no one is ever going to stop me
from living my life to the
fullest Michigan state has provided me
with several
accommodations as I am still disabled
and in extreme pain every single
day they were able to place me in a dorm
that is close to all my
classes they provide transportation for
me since walking long distances is a
battle it was a one minute walk to the
closest
cafeteria without these accommodations I
would not have been able to complete my
freshman year at Michigan
State this past summer I underwent
another spine surgery where the surgeons
fused my C6 to t7 vertebrae to stable my
spine and correct a progressing
deformity resulting from my
injury I was blessed to have found some
excellent surgeons in New York City my
family and I spent two weeks recovering
in New
York and your honor to make everyone
aware back surgery is so
hard it causes intense pain and
struggles it's impossible to do anything
yourself I needed help just to roll over
sit up stand up from a chair get in and
out of bed and sip a glass of
water my two spine surgeries took the
life out of
me besides relearning daily life tasks I
had to stop playing tennis riding horses
driving and a whole list of other things
that people can take for
granted hanging out with my friends is
hard is the best I can do is sit down
the whole
time I've been on a list of medications
for the past two years and I'm so tired
of relying on medication to keep me out
of my
misery I also have a thermo regulation
disorder resulting from my spinal cord
injury with this condition I'm unable to
stay warm in cold in cold weather or to
keep my cool body
warm or keep my body cool during warm
temperatures this is a difficult
condition to cope with as I must keep
the weather into consideration when
making any plans or just choose to stay
indoors currently I'm a sophomore at
Michigan State University where all the
accommodations are still in
place even though I am able to attend
school I'm still in constant
pain every single day when I get out of
bed the physical pain hits me hard for
reference your honor it has been 738
days of constant physical and mental
pain it has been 738 days without
playing basketball or
tennis it has been 738 days of not being
able to ride my horse
it has been 738 days of relieving the
tragedy in my head every single
hour it has been 738 days of living with
PTSD scared of the thought of someone
hurting me
again it has been 738 days of living
with Survivor guilt knowing that I could
not save Hana St
Juliana 738 days in
counting
for the rest of my life I will live with
these
struggles still to this day I'm in
physical therapy twice a week for an
hour I attend therapy where my therapist
helped to ease my ongoing
pain we are also working on regaining
all the strength back that I have
lost I will never be able to ice skate
again I will likely never be able to
take my future children sedding
I will never be able to ride a roller
coaster or jump on a trampoline ever
again I will never be able to
participate in intermural sports teams
at my
school I will never be able to attend
Sports in the student section at school
as my pain is unbearable during events
like
these my life has changed its path
entirely however your honor I refuse to
let the Cowardly acts of a person affect
the rest of my
life I will continue and live on for
those that we've
lost I will continue to walk around
msu's campus strong and
proud I will continue to have compassion
and spread love and joy and positivity
everywhere I step
foot I will continue to advocate for
those that have experienced something
similar I will proceed to stand up
against gun violence and hopes that
nothing like November 30th ever happens
to anyone ever
again and nothing will ever stop me from
living my life to the absolute
fullest no one will ever take my
happiness away from me because I'm the
strongest person I
know your honor I've experienced many
blessings and met many angels along this
journey I've come to know the love
compassion and support of a
community I have so much to thankful for
I'm grateful that I have the opportunity
to stand here before you and tell you my
story I'm so blessed with my family they
have walked with me every single step of
the
way and their strength is
astounding during both of my hospital
stays I met so many amazing
individuals who have become so my best
friends or my
family they've supported me through
every single endeavor
they took care of me and poured their
hearts into my
recovery I'm beyond
grateful for my hospital and healthc
Care family that have cared for me as if
I'm their
family and I'm so fortunate to have some
great friends who make changes to their
Lifestyles just to accommodate
mine most of all your honor I'm thankful
that I'm still
here I keep my faith and trust in a
greater plan as long as I on this Earth
I will fight for justice for everyone in
this country that has experienced
something
similar please do not let anyone else
suffer the impact and trials of our
tragedy that we hear about
today please let there be no opportunity
for more tragedy and pain because no one
deserves
this thank you for your time and I hope
my presence here today will help you
make the right decision thank you for
being here and your strength and courage
and speaking today is nothing short than
admin goal so thank you for your
statements this morning thank you me as
well